die vorderseite des magazins geht als
erstes ins gewähr
und es muss klicken die cs den hebel und
lässt ihn los klar auf einem schießstand
irgendwo auf dem balkan eine
mitarbeiterin weist mich ein
wie fühlt sich das an
erschreckend einfach spannend zielen
abdrücken
[Musik]
die waffe eine kalaschnikow serbisches
fabrikat hergestellt 1988
drei jahre vor ausbruch des krieges
[Musik]
33 jahre später funktioniert sie immer
noch
[Musik]
kriegswaffen
ihr zweck töten
der schwarzmarkt mit kriegswaffen vom
balkan blüht wer sind die käufer
kriminelle terroristen waffennarren
[Musik]
waffen aus dem jugoslawienkrieg viele
dieser waffen sind nach deutschland
gekommen illegal
häufig tauchen sie wieder auf als
tatwaffen von verbrechen
wer sind die abnehmer
[Musik]
dresden
hier beginnt meine recherche im februar
2009 10 fährt ein schwarzer mercedes suv
von der autobahn ab in richtung
innenstadt am hauptbahnhof wird der
wagen mit bosnischen kennzeichen geparkt
hinter den zwei insassen liegt eine
lange fahrt ihnen ist der sprit
ausgegangen
sie brauchen geld ein komplize soll
ihnen ein paar hundert euro zum bahnhof
bringen
währenddessen werden bundespolizisten
aus dem mercedes aufmerksam
ein schmuggler wagen wie sich zeigt die
fracht hochgefährlich rund 100
handgranaten mehrere hundert patronen
acht handfeuerwaffen fünf kalaschnikow
was auffällt einige kalaschnikows
stammen aus ddr-produktion ermittler
notieren aufgrund der massiven
gebrauchsspuren scheinen die waffen im
kriegseinsatz gewesen zu sein
der fahrer und sein begleiter werden
festgenommen
der anwalt eines angeklagten sagt es
seien nur kuriere nicht die drahtzieher
es ist ja relativ nahe liegend dass das
jetzt nicht hinz und kunz ist die an
solche waffen herankommen können an
granaten gehören nicht zum üblichen
repertoire
da sind aber sicherlich die hintermänner
die da hat den zugriff haben das was ich
davon mitbekommen habe und was aus der
akte natürlich so ein bisschen
ersichtlich war
durch die durch die usa wien kriege ist
dann natürlich immer noch ein riesiges
waffenarsenal vorhanden
nicht verbrauchte munition und ähnliches
obwohl natürlich schon sehr viel im
krieg verbraucht wurde aber es gibt
immer noch groß rechts bestände und
jetzt versucht man die eben zu versuchen
das scheint mir der naheliegende
hintergrund zu sein
in seinem aktuellen lagebericht
waffenkriminalität geht das
bundeskriminalamt davon aus dass allein
in den staaten des westbalkans
schätzungsweise sechs millionen waffen
im umlauf sind
der westbalkan das in bosnien serbien
mazedonien montenegro kosovo und
albanien rund 1000 kilometer waren die
kuriere vom bosnischen tuzla nach
dresden unterwegs
die schmuggel aktion wurde von
hintermännern gesteuert anweisung eines
mutmaßlichen drahtziehers die
nachrichten wurden von der polizei auf
dem telefon des festgenommenen fahrers
sichergestellt
alle nachrichten aus dem telefon löschen
aus dem messenger und ausfall war und
was du alles noch benutzt alles auf null
du weißt doch was ich verspreche das
mache ich auch gut okay ich teile die
alles mit wenn wir dies erledigt haben
gut bruder
ich folge den spuren der waffen in die
zentral bosnische industriestadt tus
laer
ich will wissen wie das geschäft der
waffenhändler funktioniert die
schmuggler von dresdner bahnhof stammen
aus dieser gegend mit dem kriegsausbruch
1992 kam der niedergang der bergarbeiter
region
25 prozent haben keine arbeit
perspektivlosigkeit fördert kriminalität
für die drahtzieher ist es einfach
kuriere und handlanger anzuheuern
das in dresden aufgeflogen schmuck
kleiner zwerg ging arbeitsteilig vor der
mutmaßliche drahtzieher der bande zur
tatzeit 41 jahre ist wegen drogenhandels
vorbestraft den kader und ein komplize
stehen unter verdacht die waffen in dem
mercedes versteckt zu haben
und schliesslich dino es der fahrer aus
dem schwarzen mercedes er wurde
mittlerweile in dresden wegen verstoßes
gegen das kriegswaffenkontrollgesetz zu
einer mehrjährigen haftstrafe verurteilt
es ist immer dasselbe muster bosnischen
ermittlern ist es vertrauen
[Musik]
ein teil der gruppe luftwaffen in städte
oder gemeinden sie sind vielleicht
könnte man das über einige personen
findet schwachen andere präparieren
fahrzeug handeln andere machen
kontakt damit personen in westeuropa
weil dort kann man fünffach ist so dass
ein früher für eine automatische kriegen
oder illegale pistole allein 2020 wurden
in bosnien rund 50 kalaschnikows 50
handgranaten 8000 stück munition und 13
kilogramm sprengstoff beschlagnahmt
das arsenal illegaler waffen ist größer
die dunkelziffer unbekannt
meistens finden wir das sind versteckte
teile von haus wir haben zb habe ja
handgranaten gefunden im kinderzimmer
auch sprengstoff in garagen
improvisierten versteck der stelle autos
also überall
die organisierte kriminalität in bosnien
verfügt über ein arsenal von waffen die
aus dem jugoslawienkrieg stammen
davon kann ich mir selbst ein bild
machen das ist ein lager der bosnischen
polizei mit eskorte geht die fahrt zu
einem streng bewachten lager beamte
führen mich in ein depot gerichte
bewahren hier bis zum ende eines
verfahrens beschlagnahmte waffen als
beweismittel auf
[Musik]
das ist ein granatwerfer der mit einem
gewehr ausgelöst wird
er wurde an einer wohnungstür befestigt
auch ein raketenwerfer lagert hier
damit wurde ein raubüberfall auf einen
geldtransporter verlegt und hier gibt es
noch 10 handgranaten
[Musik]
hochexplosives erwarte wenn sie eines
tages nicht mehr als beweismittel
benötigt werden steht die vernichtung
dieser waffen an die im bosnischen auto
in dresden entdeckten kalaschnikows
gehen mir nicht aus dem kopf
sie stammen aus beständen der ddr armee
nva weisen massive gebrauchsspuren auf
haben ermittler festgestellt
eigentlich hätten diese waffen niemals
auf den balkan gelangen dürfen
der westen hatte ein embargo verhängt
ich will mehr über die herkunft der
kalaschnikows erfahren wurden sie
tatsächlich im jugoslawien krieg
eingesetzt
termin in der waffen forensik von
sarajevo hier werden tatwaffen
untersucht das team arbeitet für
sicherheitsdienste und polizeibehörden
in bosnien bruno francic zeigt uns seine
sammlung diese schnellfeuerwaffe sei
sehr beliebt bei der organisierten
kriminalität
eine automatische maschinenpistole die
waffe kann man einmal drücken und das
komplette magazin verschießen es gibt
auch welche mit schalldämpfer und die
geschwindigkeit liegt bei 280 metern pro
sekunde
ursprünglich hatten offiziere so etwas
jede waffe hat ihre eigene geschichte
nicht interessiert die geschichte der
ddr waffen aus dem bosnischen schmuggler
auto in dresden haben sie eine idee wie
das in ein bosnisches schmuggler auto
kommt ich meine das entworfen was gab es
damals nicht an waffen
es existierten dutzende viele
verschiedene hersteller in
unterschiedlichen ländern russland die
sowjetunion rumänien bulgarien china ddr
davon gab es so viele wie sand am meer
[Musik]
wer aber hat mit den in dresden
beschlagnahmten waffen im jugoslawien
krieg gekämpft
ich reise von bosnien nach kroatien
kroatien kämpfte damals um seine
unabhängigkeit von jugoslawien war auf
waffenschmuggel angewiesen
in einem waffenladen nahe der
kroatischen hauptstadt zagreb treffe ich
kriegsveteranen
sie gehörten einer gruppe büchsenmacher
an die sich um die waffen der
kroatischen kämpfer kümmert als der
krieg in jugoslawien ausbrach mussten
sie eigene gewehre entwickeln
das zeigen die relikte im keller des
hauses
[Musik]
und die sieht auch aus wie so eine
eigene produktion bis auf die zwei
wurden alle in kroatischen werkstätten
gebaut
am meisten würde der mechanismus haus
russischen automatischen gewehren
entnommen
jaja ak-47 klassisches kaliber das ist
das klassische kaliber ja wir hatten das
ich erinnere mich wie die jetzt vieles
weiß ich nicht ich weiß nur dass das
eine deutsche produktion
ich treffe einen der mehr weiß es ist
ein ehemaliger seltener krank ist nicht
sein richtiger name 1992 feierte der
deutsche bei einer kroatischen einheit
an
[Musik]
ich habe gelesen dass offen balkan
waffen der nva unterwegs waren und dass
die kroaten auch saßen
habt ihr davon was mitbekommen wir
angekommen sind hatten wir noch keine
waffe und uns wurde gesagt die nächste
waffenlieferungen ist unterwegs
dann wurden wir hochgelobt unsere
zentrale und da standen etliche kisten
und auf den kisten herrscht nie
vergessen
wir haben das alle blöd angeschaut und
haben die welt nicht mehr verstanden
stand nva original verpackt in folie mit
öl alles original ak-47 ak 74 alles was
das herz begehrt war da noch ein zeichen
der mhh hat sich nicht mal die mühe
gemacht von den kisten dass er in vorab
zu machen gar nichts gar nichts
weil er zwei kameraden aus deutschland
getötet hatte verurteilte ihn ein
gericht zu lebenslanger haftstrafe
später sagte franke als zeuge gegen
einen kriegsverbrecher aus nach 18
jahren haft kam der söldner frei im
jugoslawien krieg kämpften nicht nur
deutsche auch deutsche waffen wurden
eingesetzt
als schmuggler waren kehren die ddr
kalaschnikows nun wieder nach
deutschland zurück
ermittler sind sich indes sicher dass
die gefährliche fracht am dresdner
hauptbahnhof eigentlich für empfänger in
den niederlanden bestimmt war
für wen genau das ist bis heute noch
nicht geklärt in seinem aktuellen
lagebericht waren das bundeskriminalamt
das deutschland transit und zielland von
waffen aus dem westbalkan ist mir wird
die akte eines aktuellen falles
zugespielt ich will herausbekommen wer
die empfänger solcher kriegswaffen sind
dieser hohlraum wurde schon vormals
präpariert so aufbewahrung also der
waffen und während der fahrt hat er
telefonisch noch verlangt weitere 20 bis
30 stück handgranaten zu beschaffen
meine übersetzerin liest aus der akte
vor
der fall beschäftigt mittlerweile seit
drei jahren strafverfolgungsbehörden in
kroatien österreich und deutschland
die spuren der waffen führen von
ostkroatien nach münchen in
rechtsextreme kreise
2018 überwachen kroatische behörden
waffenschmuggler
die ermittler finden heraus die männer
sprechen im kurs fällt das wort frauen
röcke sind automatische waffen gemeint
das wort bosch pumpen steht für pumpguns
ist die rede von einem ford scorpio
meinen sie die maschinenpistole scorpio
ziel der waffen deutschland so steht es
in den unterlagen
darin auch die namen der waffenhändler
ich bin in kroatien will mehr über die
bandenmitglieder herausfinden einige
haben ihre strafe bereits abgesessen
bei anderen läuft das verfahren noch was
für waffen
jetzt haben sie sie bei mir nicht
gefunden und als er sie gefunden haben
haben sie mich für zehn monate wecker
sprechen ich frage an wen die waffen
geliefert wurden
das kann ich ihnen nicht sagen wie soll
ich es ihnen sagen wenn ich jetzt nicht
weiß ich kann mit einem verurteilten
waffenschmuggler sprechen
er wohnt in einer gegend die im
jugoslawienkrieg heftig umkämpft war
uns interessiert vor allem wo kommen
eigentlich die waffen her im krieg waren
sie sehr billig man konnte sie hier
überall kaufen und man kaufte sie
einfach um eine zu haben
du konntest sie für 100 euro oder sogar
für 50 euro kaufen und viele haben sich
dann so ein gewehr gekauft
der verkäufer der kriegswaffen ich hatte
nur kontakt zu einem und dem habe ich
ein gewehr gegeben dass ich noch da
hatte ich hatte diese leute noch nie
vorher gesehen
ich habe mich auch schon mit anderen
darüber unterhalten keine waffe war für
terroristen für wen waren die waffen
bestimmt dem will ich weiter nachgehen
die meisten bandenmitglieder sind wegen
gewaltdelikten und waffenschmuggel
mehrfach vorbestraft mit einem der
drahtzieher sind wir am abend verabredet
doch als er die kamera sieht wird er
aggressiv was machst du was machst du
wer hat gesagt hast du mich films wer
hat gesagt hast du mich willst was
machst du hier
du hast nicht das haus zu drehen das ist
unsere privatsphäre
wie kommen sie auf uns das machst du
noch einmal
sie geben uns ein interview bei einer
razzia im sommer 2008 zehn stießen die
ermittler bei ihnen auf ein regelrechtes
waffendepot kriegs gewehre pistolen
munition handgranaten und ein
raketenwerfer ein bandenmitglied packt
gegenüber den kroatischen behörden aus
er nennt den mutmaßlichen waffenkäufer
er soll ein deutscher sein
sein name alexander r kroatische beamten
haben die aussage des geständigen
bandenmitglieder zusammengefasst
auszüge daraus
alexander er habe in seiner werkstatt in
deutschland waffen in einem pkw golf
gepackt einige kalaschnikows einige
pumpguns er interessiere sich für
automatische waffen kurzwaffen pumps
skorpione und kalaschnikows die waffen
die er nach deutschland fuhr sein für
die afd
eine rechte partei vorgesehen gewesen
eine brisante aussage
doch was ist dran der deutsche alexander
erlebt in einer kroatischen hafenstadt
von hier aus soll er waffendeals
organisiert haben
im sommer wurde an die bayerische justiz
ausgeliefert
was ist von dem geständnis des
kroatischen bandenmitglieds zu halten
er soll in einer münchner autowerkstatt
arbeiten
ich treffe ihnen nicht an ich
hinterlasse eine nachricht irgendwann
ruft er zurück
ich habe gesehen was sie ausgesagt haben
der mittelsmann wiegelt ab er sei in
kroatien zu dem geständnis erpresst
worden habe es inzwischen widerrufen
also stimmt das gar nicht dass alexander
r
an personen im umfeld der afg waffen
geliefert hat seit sommer 2020 sitzt
alexander r
in untersuchungshaft und wartet auf den
ausgang seines ermittlungsverfahrens der
mutmaßliche waffendeal lässt seinen
anwalt sprechen
mein mandant hat er bestätigt nicht dass
er waffen ein mitglieder der fdp
abgegeben hat um irgendwelche blick
hatten zehn damit aufzurüsten
was dagegen einräumt ist dass er damals
in kontakt stand mit seiner meinung nach
unpolitischen sammlern von deko waffen
und zu diesen personen gesagt hatte und
waffen abgegeben hat die aber nicht
funktionsfähig gewesen sind
gibt es verbindungen zwischen alexander
r und der afd
ich habe zu einem experten der die
rechtsextreme szene in bayern kennt
kontakt aufgenommen
ich bin fündig geworden robert andreas
recherchiert seit jahren in der
rechtsextremen szene
ich habe ihn gefragt ob er informationen
über alexander r
den mutmaßlichen waffenkäufer hat
finanzwirt von beruf hat als ich ihn
kennengelernt habe als neonazi beim voll
gearbeitet das war also 2009 weil
durchgängig quasi in der münchner nazi
szene aktiv in dieser zeit war alexander
npd-mitglied später trat er in die afg
aufnahmen einer veranstaltung in bayern
von 2016
mittendrin alexander r der kreisverband
münchen land bestätigt die afg
mitgliedschaft von alexander r
seine npd vergangenheit habe er
verschwiegen laut ermittlungsakten
beteiligte sich alexander er auch an der
bildung einer unterstützerorganisation
für den rechtsextremen flügel von afg
politiker björn höcker
eine spur führt zu einer mitarbeiterin
eines afd wahlkreisbüros in münchen
dagmar es soll eine geschmuggelte waffen
aufbewahrt haben bereits 2017 wurde sie
auf bewährung wegen unerlaubten besitzes
einer halbautomatischen waffe verurteilt
da ist ein will sich nicht ich habe mich
auch schon laut akte soll dagmar es
sogar auf waffen kurierfahrt nach
kroatien gehen nur ein defekt am auto
habe das verhindert
seit 2009 10 bearbeitet die münchner
generalstaatsanwaltschaft den
waffenschmuggel komplex alexander er
gelte als hauptbeschuldigter sagt der
behördensprecher klaus ruland das
ergebnis dieser zweiten durchsuchung im
juli gewesen das haben sie
herausgefunden
bei unserem haupttäter und im
wesentlichen bei vielen abnehmern
man hat hier waffen gefunden unter
anderem zwei halbautomatische kurzwaffe
einen schießkugelschreiber und auch eine
sogenannte pumpgun und daneben auch noch
200 schuss munition wir haben 15
beschuldigte davon sind 13 abnehmer die
weisen zum großteil rechtsextremes
gedankengut auf man kann also hören die
dem rechtsextremen spektrum zuordnen
lässt sie liegt auf der linken seite
was verbindet all die unter waffen
verdacht geratenen personen im
sächsischen zeithain schlugen die
ermittler zu
aus chats von alexander r ließ sich
entnehmen dass bodo h an waffendeals
beteiligt war
ein bekannter von haar sagt er sei nicht
da äußern wolle er sich auch nicht in
der nähe der sachsen-anhaltischen
stadthalle durchkämmten polizisten die
wohnung von steffen hupka einem
langjährigen npd kader in münchen und
umland nahmen sich die beamten wohn und
geschäftsräume von verdächtigen vor
beschuldigt auch eine über 80-jährige
rentnerin
sie gab zu protokoll eine pistole für
1150 euro bei einem mann gekauft zu
haben den sie auf einer fdp mitglieder
veranstaltung getroffen hat
sie habe die pistole in einem wald
ausprobiert
hallo grüß dich was verbindet denn all
diese personen die jetzt im zusammenhang
mit mit den waffen ermittlungen zutage
getreten sind all die personen kennen
sich untereinander und haben sich bei
p&g dann münchen aber auch in den
strukturen der fc bayern gesehen und all
die personen hatten wohl den eindruck
dass sie mehr wollen dass sie
entschlossen sind da sie noch was
zusätzlich aufbauen wollen
da sind noch eine weitere organisation
brauchen entweder parallel zur afg oder
um die afg noch weiter nach rechts zu
drücken wenn es möglich ist
noch laufen die ermittlungen in dem
waffenschieber verfahren wie groß das
netzwerk wirklich wahr und was mit den
waffen passieren sollte ist bislang
nicht bekannt
waffen vom balkan bedrohen die
sicherheit europas klar und deutlich in
bosnien möchte ich wissen was gegen die
vielen waffen aus dem jugoslawien krieg
unternommen wird zwei leute bringen die
kiste zu dem loch als an den ort an
denen sie zerstört werden sollen
dieser job ist gefährlich vielleicht
sogar der gefährlichste bei der polizei
aber wir machen den job schon ziemlich
lange seit dem krieg seit 25 jahren
jeden tag werden diese polizisten mit
dem explosiven erbe des krieges
konfrontiert
manchmal haben wir mehr munition
heute haben wir nur drei handgranaten
manche tage haben wir 20 bis 30 diese
handgranaten waren beweismittel in einem
gerichtsverfahren
die richter haben sie zur vernichtung
freigegeben die serie geht wenn es rot
leuchtet haben wir volles signal dann
kann mir
können wir hier vor
drei handgranaten unschädlich gemacht
sie können nicht mehr als schmuggelware
nach deutschland kommen
[Musik]
auf initiative von frankreich und
deutschland vereinbaren 2018 die
westbalkanstaaten eine sogenannte
roadmap der plan sieht vor dass die
einstigen kriegsgegner gemeinsam die
illegalen waffen ströme eindämmen
regionale kooperation statt gegnerschaft
es ist die botschaft und in diesem
geiste weil wir ja auch hier auf dieser
konferenz engagiert mit ihm
weiterarbeiten
drei jahre sind seither vergangen und
noch immer weiß der westbalkan eine der
weltweit höchsten waffen dichte auf
[Musik]
in der serbischen hauptstadt belgrad
überwacht die organisation aiesec im
auftrag der un die umsetzung der roadmap
eine datenbank erfasst wie viele
straftaten mit waffen verübt werden wie
viele gewehre und pistolen beschlagnahmt
wurden wir sehen dass es an allen orten
2020 dass es insgesamt an allen orten
1225 waffen beschlagnahmungen auch 25
jahre nach kriegsende sind die waffen
ströme auf dem balkan noch immer nicht
unter kontrolle
das betrifft auch die strafverfolgung
das reicht vom grenzschutz und der
polizeiarbeit dass man die waffen besser
aufspürt und dann auch die fälle von
illegalem waffenhandel ermittelt und
dann braucht es natürlich auch
staatsanwälte die den illegalen besitz
und die verwendung von waffen auch
wirklich vor gericht bringen
es ist nicht so als würden die behörden
auf dem westbalkan nichts unternehmen
hier werden gewehre eingeschmolzen
aber es sind immer noch sehr viele
waffen unterwegs und viele gelangen in
falsche hände und das stellt nach wie
vor eine große gefahr dar für die
menschen auf dem balkan aber auch für
alle anderen in europa es muss mehr
unternommen werden um die tödliche
gefahr illegaler waffen ein für allemal
zu beenden
[Musik]